Speaker 1: All right. Something super
interesting is starting to happen within
the Republican Party. There is a campaign that
has started a silent campaign or let's not say
a quiet campaign to be Donald Trump's running
mate in 2024. Now, Donald Trump hasn't even
announced many of Donald Trump's endorses, did
terribly in the midterms and lost. There are
increasingly Republicans who say Donald Trump
shouldn't even run. And as we recently saw,
the betting markets now feel that it
is more likely that Ron DeSantis is the
2024 Republican nominee than it is Trump. But
there are Trump sycophants, the Trump suck ups,
the Trump Brown posers who are desperate to be
Donald Trump's running mate. One such individual
is radical Republican Congresswoman Marjorie
Taylor GREENE. Marjorie Taylor GREENE has
been floated as a possibility for Donald Trump's
running mate in 2024. We know that Donald Trump,
after his falling out with Mike Pence, will not
be choosing Pence to run with him in 24 if indeed
he chooses to be a candidate. And there have
also been rumblings of is it possible that Ron
DeSantis would run or be Trump's VP? I don't think
that's likely. Is it possible that Carrie Lake,
if she becomes governor, would then try to become
Trump's VP? Marjorie Taylor GREENE doesn't like
it. And Marjorie Taylor GREENE is now framing
this as DeSantis and Lake shouldn't abandon
their states. Abandon their states. This is very
interesting. Marge is angling to be Trump's VP.
Speaker 2: Earlier, we also talked and we said
if anyone steps into the political ring and
tries to challenge President Trump as far
as being the Republican nominee for 2024,
we feel like it's political suicide. This
is his party. This is his race to run. Do
you want to share your thoughts on that?
Speaker 1: Yesterday's results call that
assessment and the question, by the way.
Speaker 4: Absolutely. I think that
it's clear and obvious. President Trump is the
people's choice. He's the one that we elected
in 2016. We reelected him in 2020 and we will
elect him in 2024. What we need in this country,
Brian, is we need strong Republican governors
like Ron DeSantis. We need strong Republican
governors. We need Kerry like to win in Arizona.
We need strong Republican governors to fight,
stay in for eight years and save their states,
not to abandon their states and try to run for
president or any other big position.
Speaker 1: So I wonder
why she feels that way then.
Speaker 4: Just for everyone. Anyone
that's considering running for president in 2024
against President Trump, please support President
Trump because we need him back in the White House.
Speaker 1: Yeah. And we need him to be the nominee
so that he picks me to be his running mate. Only
a Trump supporter would view other candidates
engaging in the democratic process as an act
of betrayal. Think about how backwards that is.
Think about it. Marjorie Taylor GREENE is saying.
If you don't simply lay down and let Trump have
the nomination if he wants it, it's in some way
a betrayal. If you're a governor and you say,
I'm going to go run for president, you're
abandoning your state. All of this stuff
is completely self-serving. And by the way,
Marjorie Taylor GREENE wants to be VP despite
the fact that she has done absolutely nothing for
her constituents as a representative for the state
of Georgia. They need, Trump confirmed as the de
facto candidate quickly because they want to put
political pressure on the investigations
that are taking place to try to end them.
They have a lot of different reasons why they
want Trump to very quickly announce and have
everyone else get out of the way. If indeed Trump
follows through with announcing next Tuesday,
that's part of the motivation. They want everybody
to get out of the way. They want to use it to try
to suppress investigations, but also they want
to move on to this PR campaign for who will Trump
choose as his running mate. Marjorie
Taylor GREENE wants to be that person.